so to make a zombie you can use a
variety of materials if you're working
at home you might have better access to
some materials like latex a latex you
can use to build up wounds usually with
tissue paper or even toilet paper and
that's a quick and easy simple way of
creating wounds that will last for hours
and hours so I'm gonna use my latex and
begin to build up wounds on the face I'm
gonna start by stippling a layer on and
then I'm gonna take tissue paper I'm
gonna separate the plies and lay it into
the wet latex between each layer of
tissue I'm going to apply another layer
of latex so I'm just stippling the latex
over the tissue and then I'm feathering
it out onto the skin you want to apply
about two to three layers of tissue and
latex onto the face and before it dries
I'm just gonna take my metal spatula or
you can take a tongue depressor and just
begin to tear into it and form your
wound then I'm gonna take my latex and
just stipple one final layer on top
so this is a pretty basic makeup it's a
water activated makeup that's really
great to use for Halloween it's easy to
apply it's easy to remove this is a
porous pink round sponge this is really
good to use with the water activated
colors and what I'm gonna do just to
prep it I'm gonna take the sponge and
pluck little pieces out of it and what
that's gonna create is a nice texture
stamp a lot of people want white and
black for zombie colors and you just
have to think in terms of what colors
actually exist in human skin so I'm
using you know bruising colors so I'm
just carrying a little bit of the
bruising colors up onto the rest of the
face just to break up the base color a
little bit make it look a little more
textured
I'm just going back into the wounds and
just refining them a little bit going in
with those dark bruising colors another
product that you might want to
incorporate into your zombie makeup is
this temple white I'm just gonna add a
little bit of white to the hair using a
disposable mascara wand so we're gonna
take the black tooth enamel and go right
up into the gum line and into the cracks
of the teeth and finally we added blood
to finish the look
you